-Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news
and think, "That headline
could be much better"?
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ "News and Improved" ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
That headline can definitely
be improved,
'cause if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
Like, yes!
Check out this next photo.
The original headline was...
But if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Laughter, applause ]
I didn't know those existed.
Never heard of those.
Up next, this headline says...
But the headline
could have been...
"Hey, hey!
Uh, uh, uh...
Guy?"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Should have waited
for after the game.
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
She wrote it in glow pen.
Up next, this headline says...
The headline could have been...
Oh, I'm excited for that.
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
Good for you.
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."